Hallo zusammen! Heute gibt's eine Ramadan Torte, beziehungsweise eher eine Bayram Torte!
Das ist das Ramadanfest, oder wie es auf Arabisch heißt..?
[Hamza] Eid!
[Kiki] Das ist immer dieses Wort, das ich nicht aussprechen kann wegen dem Buchstaben. Eid!
[Kiki] Eid.. ich kann's nicht!
[Hamza] Eid al Fitr nennt man das auch!
[Kiki] Eid al Fitr.. oh mein Gott!
Es ist jedes Jahr dasselbe! Ich kann's auf Arabisch nie aussprechen weil mein Hals das einfach nicht mitmacht.
Aber sei's drum! Es geht ja hier um die Torte und um den leckeren Geschmack.
Wir machen einen leckeren Dattelboden.
Generell Rezepte mit Datteln, also süße Rezepte mit Datteln haben ja schon ganz viele von mir gewünscht
und ich habe mir einen richtig leckeren Boden einfallen lassen.
Den habe ich ausprobiert, der hat mir super, super gut geschmeckt.
Und dafür nehmen wir uns jetzt Datteln, am besten richtig schöne, dicke saftige mit viel Fleischanteil - mit viel Fruchtfleisch.
Ich nehme natürlich Medjool Datteln, das sind unsere aus Palästina
und die werde ich jetzt erstmal entkernen und dann sehr fein schneiden
und anschließend in Milch geben, aber das zeige ich euch gleich nochmal.
So, meine Datteln gebe ich jetzt hier in die Milch und dann das Ganze ungefähr 2-3min lang köcheln lassen.
Die Dattel-Milchfüllung dann einfach schön abkühlen lassen und dann geht's weiter mit den restlichen Zutaten.
Ich schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Und ich habe jetzt hier in meiner Schüssel zimmerwarme Butter, gebe da braunen Zucker dazu,
ihr könnt auch ganz normalen weißen nehmen, der hat für mich einen karamelligeren Geschmack.
Genauso wie die Medjool Datteln, die schmecken übetrieben karamellig. Ihr müsst da mal probieren!
Da gebe ich auch ein Ei mit dazu und verrühre das Ganze jetzt 1min lang.
Direkt danach die Dattel-Milchmasse unterrühren, das müsst ihr nur ganz kurz.
Und anschließend sieben wir schon die trockenen Zutaten dazu, das sind Mehl, Backkakao und Backpulver.
Das Ganze auch nur kurz unterrühren und fertig ist schon der Teig, das ging super, super schnell!
Ich fülle ihn jetzt in einen Spritzbeutel und ich sag euch gleich auch warum, das wird euch helfen
und schneide vorne die Spitze ab und danach machen wir uns an die Mondsichel Form.
Ihr müsst nämlich keine Backform da haben, sondern wir tricksen gleich ein bisschen.
Für die Backform brauchen wir jetzt 2 Tortenringe,
ihr könntet aber auch z.B. eine Springform und einen Tortenring nehmen falls ihr keine 2 Ringe Zuhause habt.
Wichtig ist nur, dass es eine Mondsichel ergibt und das funktioniert ganz einfach
indem man 2 Ringe ineinander steckt und den inneren einfach an den Rand schiebt
und dann hat man schon eine Mondsichel!
Ich habe jetzt hier die Maße 25 und 17cm, aber ihr könnt da auch ganz einfach variieren.
Und jetzt einfach den Teig einfüllen und dann backen, die Backzeit verrate ich euch auch schonmal:
180° C Ober- und Unterhitze, ganz wichtig: immer vorheizen den Backofen!
Und dann braucht der Boden 18min.
Ich mache in der Zwischenzeit die Creme und die ist auch super einfach.
Da wollte ich einfach nur leckere, cremige Zutaten nehmen, das Ganze mit Vanille verfeinern..
Und der Boden ist halt super aufregend, deshalb wollte ich's oben einfach nur lecker und cremig haben.
Ich nehme jetzt hier Mascarpone, Schmand, dann habe ich noch Doppelrahmfrischkäse.
Da fragen mich immer viele: "Welchen soll ich nehmen damit er nicht zu salzig schmeckt?"
Ich persönlich mag z.B. Philadelphia ganz gerne.
Puderzucker kommt dazu, Vanilleextrakt und ein bisschen Sahnefest.
Und dann rühren wir das so kurz wie möglich zusammen, also es sind am Ende wirklich nur so 20sek.
Und zack, ist die Creme auch schon fertig!
Es ist wirklich ein schnelles Rezept aber es braucht auch einfach nicht lange, es ist einfach so!
Wir machen jetzt auch direkt weiter, ich hab jetzt hier meinen Tortenheber schon bereit.
Mein Kuchen ist abgekühlt, macht gerne was drüber damit er euch nicht austrocknet
aber der ist an sich super saftig, allein schon durch die Butter und durch die Datteln.
So, ich werd das jetzt hier einmal runternehmen, das geht auch ganz schnell und schmerzlos.
Und dann einfach die Creme drauf verteilen. Warum lachst du?
So, ich habe das jetzt hier schön verstrichen und kühle das jetzt für 15-20min.
So, die Kühlzeit ist um. Ich werde das Ganze jetzt verlagern auf eine schöne Schieferplatte
und dann die 2 Ringe entfernen. Und das macht ihr -
Also das Verlagern geht wirklich - ne? In null Komma nix!
Das macht ihr am besten mit 'nem Backformlöser, dass ihr dann den Rand schön löst.
Es wird auf jeden Fall der Fall sein, dass ihr nochmal mit einer Winkelpalette dran müsst und das Ganze nochmal schön glatt streicht.
Die größte Herausforderung ist bei diesem Rezept tatsächlich, dass man die Enden der Mondsichel schön fein verstreicht
aber ich glaube das mache ich dann gleich wenn ich das alles entfernt habe.
So, als nächstes kommt der Guss, also der Drip
und dann geben wir nur noch Baklava, Erdbeeren,
gefriergetrocknete Früchte etc. obendrauf, eigentlich alles, wonach euch ist.
Beim Guss muss ich sagen: Ich nehme jetzt meine Haselnusscreme, die habe ich hier in warmem Wasser erwärmt.
Das geht auch in der Mikrowelle und die Creme fülle ich mir jetzt hier einmal rein und schneide vorne die Spitze ab.
Und natürliche finde ich jetzt meine Haselnusscreme an der Stelle am leckersten aber ihr könnt auch einen normalen Guss nehmen mit Kuvertüre.
Das solltet ihr dann ein bisschen verdünnen mit Kokosfett, schreibe ich euch aber unten in die Infobox auf.
Wer meine Creme hat, sollte das jetzt unbedingt mal probieren weil das auch geschmacklich super gut harmoniert.
Und danach einfach nur noch dekorieren und das war's!
Ich hab natürlich von meinen Baklava und von meinen Lokums drauf gegeben,
ich werd euch alles unten in die Infobox verlinken. Ihr dürft natürlich eurer Fantasie freien Lauf lassen!
Ansonsten hoffe ich, dass euch meine Idee gefallen hat, dass ihr's fleißig nachmachen werdet.
Verlinkt mich unbedingt auf Instagram damit ich eure Kreationen sehen und reposten kann
und ansonsten wünsche ich euch ein wundervolles Bayram, ein schönes Fest an alle, die feiern.
Und bleibt alle gesund. Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!